okay so here we are it's me Andrew once
again on eating your feed the show where
we recreate foods from viral videos and
today I'm doing something called meat
fruit and I'm being challenged by Shane
Maday yes you are
Shane Maday from BuzzFeed's unsolved
Network give it a watch are ghosts real
no check it out
alvin on tasty actually went to this
restaurant dinner by Heston Blumenthal
what appears to be a mandarin orange on
a board but then when you cut into it
inside there's a meat paste
it's a pate which is kind of like
blended up usually livers into like a
spreadable tasty paste of meat luckily
for such a difficult recipe we were able
to get the cookbook
it's called historic Heston mr.
Blumenthal himself wrote at the recipe I
love when a book has this thing you know
it's gonna be good this meat fruit is
essentially taking a tasty puree putting
that into a half-circle
mold breezing that taking those two
halves putting them together into now a
perfect circle dipping that into orange
jelly that will coat the outside why am
I making this this dish I want to be
surprised and delighted okay well I hope
I won't disappoint you so I'm going to
ask culinary advisor all-around good
person ray mcclenney to give me some
words of advice hi ray hi I'm making the
meat fruit today I think you've gotten a
peek at the recipe yes it's gonna be
pretty hard right it's very difficult
I think I'm not gonna make his pate
recipe okay they use this machine that
circulates while it cooks their pate and
it costs like $1,500 Wow I want to make
a more simple one okay pets they should
be fairly easy though that one if you'll
find about okay for this jelly I'm
worried about it just turning into a
pool on the plate I've seen that before
yeah I could just avoid puddle plate
I'll be pretty pleased with myself yeah
okay so a couple notes about the recipe
I'm going to do some stuff we were not
able to obtain couldn't get glucose but
we have corn syrup which i think is like
maybe 80% the same thing 40 grams of
corn syrup we got 1 kilogram of Mandarin
puree here and the recipe begins by
adding half of that amount I'm gonna
start warming that up you're just gonna
eyeball it like that yeah I'm heating
this up to 120 Mason jet off Oh
everything is sticky now I hate this
this feeling 90 degrees Fahrenheit this
is a merry old English recipe we'll do
this one in the metric thing Celsius
part of the metric system I consider
those one in the same we're at 34 I need
to get to 50 I don't know what happens
if I exceed that but I don't want to
find out
speaking of Blumenthal I'm gonna bloom
my gelatin now look at that that's a
sheet of bronze gelatin bronze gelatin
is a grade of gelatin where you also
have silver and gold and I think it
determines how firm it will be okay
break this in half wait okay you can't
you can't do that you freaking kidding
me
well that is hard now I cover it with
cold water sure why not and I will set a
timer for five minutes
it's like sheets of jelly this rivals
the time that Patrick and I massage the
bowl of eggs doesn't roll in your hands
through a bunch of eggs if I were you I
can use acrylic so the concept is
hard-boiled eggs in a bathtub
do you see that how funny does that look
oh my god this is some Star Wars this is
truly one of the weirdest things I've
ever touched do you like it
I really do I'll just put this in my
warm to liquid now okay
oh it's dissolving pretty quickly oh
okay it's gone so I'm just gonna do a
portion of this into here and then I'm
gonna make a little color cocktail here
when we start with base orange do two
drops okay oh boy extremely orange II
I'm gonna add a drop of yellow mm-hmm
okay now I'm gonna add this back this is
not how this is supposed to go okay so
the next step is to pass it through a
sieve to make sure it's really nice and
smooth and then oh it's getting very uh
oh dude it's getting so jelly
I'm worried wait what's the what's wait
a second that's a quick little ball so
tomorrow when I dip the jelly oh my god
it's becoming so jelly you see the
consistency it's no good oh my god do
you see what's happening in this pot
right now that's gonna be tough to sieve
are you kidding me we're gonna warm it a
touch I mean that way are you kidding me
an EDA
my second portion of Mandarin puree was
still like a little icing so maybe it
dropped the temperature too much so I'm
gonna gently warm this
[Music]
mmm delicious jello yeah all right
everything's gonna be a little sticky
after this portion of the recipe but
we're gonna have to deal okay move to a
slightly larger vessel
I found a larger pitcher we're gonna go
with this should I put it back through
the sieve Oh double sieve yeah I'll just
do that
Oh God we're losing it you think you're
flopping one way and it can go opps the
other that's gonna be it
okay that's gonna be it what are you
tasting my jelly yeah we're jelly
frankly I'd put this on toast hmm you
guys heard of oh that's good
jelly that's going in the cool tank for
24 hours so the pate recipe that we're
following is closest to this Mark
Bittman New York Times creamy chicken
liver pate as you can see I'm no longer
wearing the sweater I was wearing
earlier it's eaten up so at its core we
have the chicken livers which has the
consistency of like a waterbed and fun
fact the cashier at the supermarket
asked me if I was gonna feed them to my
dog which I guess is a thing people do
and then we got duck fat because the
original recipe has foie gras this
recipe has butter so I thought we'll
swap this and that'll steer it more
towards the fatty bird territory and you
know add some fanciness to this recipe
all right so to begin I'll slice up
these onions is a shallot not an onion
but no it's not if there was a onion
Club and a shallot wanted to come would
they turn it away yes
it's coming now the - no all right I'm
just gonna take some of that do not find
curing salt but I did find pink
Himalayan salt which I'm sure somebody's
gonna tell me that not gonna do the same
thing but you know what this is all we
got so I've my spice grinder here to
which I will add 10 black peppercorns 2
allspice berries a clove 4 coriander
seeds okay cool it's all good I saved it
and now I'm gonna add my livers to the
onions oh that is a gnarly sight let me
tell you do you know Adam you've cooked
livers in the past right am I supposed
to like rinse them or anything you never
cooked livers these look ready to go I'm
just gonna pop them in there's also some
kind of tubular dude in here are those
the veins oh okay
whatever that is that's just throw their
veins on there are those those little
squiggly I'm googling removing liver
vein for cooking do this up royally do
these look veiny to you there's some
gnarly looking stuff on here and
neglected to clean so plop them right
back in as I go if it looks like I don't
know what I'm doing it's because I have
no idea yeah he said he kind of wanted
his to still be pink in the center my
livers are about F overcooked and half
nice and bloody so I call it their food
processor meat livers my spice mix into
the food processor two tablespoons of
brandy this feels ridiculous well plop
in a stick of butter into a blender with
meat mm-hmm oh I forgot to add a third
of a cup of cream that should make it a
little bit lighter oh that's so thick
okay barely a barely a difference so the
heston blumenthal
final product is like a strawberry
sorbet inside why is it so different
this looks like I've never made pate
before why don't you try a little bit of
it that was yeah that was chill know
what you know if that was chilled Oh
tastes mad good right there is a there's
a lingering bitterness she's a little
minerality to it for her yeah you're
supposed to clean livers apparently
before you cook them just took the
fastest trip to the grocery store ever
it would have been slightly faster had I
stayed in the checkout line that I was
in but it was the same guy as before so
I swapped the lines to hide my shame
while I was waiting in that line I did
some googling and I learned that what
you should do is soak your livers in
water so that's what I'm gonna do here
Della's horrifying I'm not feeling good
about this anymore
flashback to when I thought the gelatin
would be the hard part I was like oh
yeah you just blend up chicken livers
and then you got pet day no I'm gonna do
a white onion this time which hopefully
that will keep the color a little
brighter
instead of shallots instead of shallots
yeah sure lows okay
[Music]
did you keep trying to go fast oh that's
okay let's get a band-aid oh yeah well
we already cut don't worry about that so
I'm gonna recut my onion we've
sterilized the area ah fooled you
I was good really yeah I'm also going to
try real hard not to brown the onions at
all just sweating like me okay my livers
look not bad so what I'm gonna do now is
take each one out and try to remove any
connective tissue or ugly stuff attached
to it and put that in a separate Bowl I
go through all this work to try to make
it taste fine and it tastes bad then I'm
just gonna buy chicken liver pate you
know freeze it my spices same mixture as
before I'll do one tablespoon of brandy
this time there's a little too boozy
last time right yep here they come blop
I'm stressed
it's definitely rosier than before
it smells less disgusting than earlier
they hate this there's a there's a
lightness to it a sponge Enis it is a
sponginess the first one tasted like
there's blood in your mouth
here I have my silicone mold so I'm
going to fill up my piping bag it would
appear to be a little looser than
optimally desired okay maybe boys just
sound like people while you do this okay
these will go in the freezer now
overnight I'm a little worried we're
gonna we're gonna eat something tomorrow
it might just be puddle plate pate so
yesterday we made the jelly which had to
rest overnight we made our pate as a
backup we also have some pate from a
local fine butcher store called when
here in Los Angeles and this should be
delicious okay so time to do a taste
test okay Oh so I guess the outside of
my pate oxidized but when I scrape it
away it's actually a rosier color inside
it actually looks identical it's not bad
it's not gross in any way but I
definitely should not have added all the
spices
yeah the aftertaste is really metallic
let's try this
oh and see graters has a grey on top too
oh my god is it much better that's
delicious
okay
[Applause]
there they are Wow okay we've got a
blowtorch which I will use to soften up
the edge of the sphere it has the
texture of like a frozen Wendy's frosty
for sure but it is meat yeah it stuck
together I mean it's not great it's
there's some separation there I think I
can use a little bit of my reserved pate
as a spackle you're like Bob Ross with
this thing okay I'm gonna go toss these
back in the freezer now for a little bit
of a insurance policy I'm going to take
our butcher store purchased pate and put
those in our silicone semi spheres it's
like a weird toothpaste this is the kind
of satisfying activity that I was really
hoping for with this challenge
I'm gonna pop these in the freezer and I
need to start warming my Mandarin jelly
the recipe really warns not to exceed a
certain temperature with a mandarin
jelly so it needs to be gradually warmed
and held at a specific temperature so
that's why we're using this water
circulator okay hey good morning
just gonna top this off oh wait a second
what happened misread the instructions a
little bit what I'm supposed to do now
is take all this manner and jelly put it
in a saucepan gently bring it back to a
liquid state ensuring that it doesn't go
over 40 degrees Celsius is it really
supposed to be like that probably the
gelatin are they melting that's kind of
hard to tell
yeah there's oh yeah there's some little
oil liquid is forming at the bottom and
now into the immersion circulator great
it's submerged in water well we have a
few more minutes the half spheres from
the butcher store pate are pretty firm
and I think I can form them into circles
now into the freezer this is my battle
station for dipping the spheres into the
orange jelly each sphere is going to
go into the jelly two times then stick
on here this goes in the fridge for a
minute and then I do it as many times as
necessary to have a satisfying coating
on the outside all right here we go
all of these steps have led up to this
moment
[Music]
okay I'm gonna put that into the fridge
okay I'm gonna dip again okay it's
starting to look really cool
it's now like a shiny orange sphere this
is very shiny and smooth into the fridge
how to remove the stick do you see the
way it jiggles there's definitely a lot
of gelatin oh this is cool it's fun this
is the fun part so these ones went in
the freezer which gave them more of a
texture I think that's gonna contribute
to the final orange flesh type texture
this is the best one yet dude
yeah the freezer gives it a matte finish
immediately net and wrinkly okay I've
got the good pate I feel really good
about this it's going straight in the
freezer okay
just waiting for those balls to freeze I
think this is the best one so far it's
dimply but not too shiny oh yeah it's
got a nice texture to it a nice orange
color it's got the light colored pate
inside so I'm gonna pop this off and put
it in the refrigerator so the pate
spheres have been in the fridge now for
almost 6 hours we've got a nice loaf of
bread from Tartine bakery here in Los
Angeles that we're going to use to serve
the pate with that's how it's served at
the restaurant the best parts of this
episode are all the things that I've
just bought ok now a nice thick slice
that I'll toast up oh oh
these are the two that came from the
Gwen pate you can see the colors a lot
lighter and we started to get the
texture nail down I think this is my
hero orange here's the VIP cutting board
we have our little spreader knife some
leaves that we took from a not orange
tree but not poisonous tree outside my
bread
how's that oh my god that is really very
impressive all right I'm gonna get Rea
in here okay don't open your eyes yet so
you remember what the meat fruit looks
like yes open your eyes Wow you say the
best job ready to make them so Alvin
cuts a full face off of it okay you know
honestly I think yours looks better yeah
I'm not kidding yeah I'm gonna come
right across the front here
Oh oh yeah this is definitely the
coolest thing I've ever really yeah I am
surprised and delighted
[Music]
good are you kidding me so good stop it
laughing yeah you want to try the one
with the pate that I mean yeah sure
it's pup egg should I be prepared I'll
try it first I'll be the guinea pig that
doesn't look good
yeah thanks shame for opening my eyes to
what the world of roots shaped meats is
like thank you for nailing it except for
the liver I'd like to now show it to
somebody who has no idea what it is
welcome Aria hello hi thank you for
having me
you don't really know what's happening
right now absolutely no idea thought
this would make it fancy I know I'm
gonna show you a plate of food and I'd
like you to just have a bite in whatever
way you think is appropriate
all right here it is oh all right
yeah all right just almost like like I
like it okay or however you think you
should eat it mmm give him the context
clues you know well that his breath oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I had to touch
okay I do I'm he's dead whatever you
want to do whatever is drawing you in
whatever things are oh oh that's
gelatinous ah yes it is right there yeah
oh by the way I thought there was some
ooze coming out okay that's great
that's why you like that this is
something what's that man the man the
English guy bald Heston you know has
some Blumenthal oh yes I do them know by
name and by a couple of shows this is a
Heston Blumenthal dish how do you know
well Wow we ask the right person to come
into this food Heston well done has been
fantastic I didn't know it was that has
a little dish I've ever eaten at a
Heston Blumenthal restaurant know what
love to while now I have the experience
all right that's been eating your feed
[Music]
you